and here is tylor
t-y-l-o-r and he does want to pronounce
ty lore not tyler mcgill
yeah and you'll see you can see right
away six foot seven
what i like about him he's got a really
long stride an extension
bouncing ball to third jd davis on a
short hop across the diamond you've got
to get rid of it quickly to get turner
and he does
rips this one down the right field line
it'll go to the wall muncie around first
heading for second
almora gets it back in stand up double
the count goes to three and two on corey
seeger two outs max muncie at second
base top of the first
this ball is well struck to center field
back goes brandon
nemo and he can't run it down it's one
hop off the wall muncie scores easily
and seeger pulls up at second with an
rbi double
reyes trying to become the major's first
14-game winner this season kyle
hendricks of the cubs had a crack at it
yesterday but the brewers treated him
very rudely at wrigley field
on the first pitch drury lifts a mile
high fly ball into left center field
and it's aj pollock for the catch
the mets go in order in the bottom of
the first
and the dodgers lead it after one one
nothing
gill probably changed his shirt after
throwing 32 pitches and he had to hustle
back out to the mound
chris taylor rips one to left
and it will fall in front of kevin palla
third hit for the dodgers
that have not had much luck with the
dodgers over the last few years
and bellinger a big reason why there's a
change up right in the middle of the
plate
from mcgill and bellinger missed it
badly
he was i don't want to say
untouchable but close to that certainly
this young man was
aureus
on three pitches down he goes
through two frames mcgill has struck out
four will smith
struck out his first time
will smith hammers this one to left
center field going back to the edge of
the track to take it as pilar it'll be a
sacrifice fly turner scores two nothing
dodgers that's his natural stroke
because as a youngster
he was lucky enough to have an influence
who said learn how to hit the ball the
other way
and as we talk about miguel mcgill
strikes out
first strikeout of the night for uras
and down he goes second strikeout of the
night for jurias
nimo is stranded at first now trey
turner comes to the plate bases loaded
one out
he smacks this one to left center field
back goes nimmo on the track to make the
catch it'll bring a third run home
bellinger scores mckinney tags and moves
to third three-nothing l.a
he's a big right-handed thrower he
embraces 13 though you know that
and drury is disposed of rather quickly
third strikeout for uras
and they may have to just back off the
pedal a little bit
called third strike to jd davis
it's the fourth strikeout of the night
but the third in a row for urias
and another one-two pitch to pollock
breaking ball lifted to left
and that'll do it
as pallar puts it away
a one two three fifth for mcgill
pinch hitter and it's dominic smith
lefty lefty two on one out
and the mets down three
struck him out
reach back for something extra and blew
it by him upstairs at 95. fifth
strikeout for aureus brandon nimo's one
for two and on the first pitch
he sends a lazy harmless fly ball to
left aj pollock takes it
qualified for what could be his 14th win
the mets leave two and they still trail
it three nothing
first man he faces is chris taylor
who promptly drives one to deep left
center field and it will split them and
go to the wall taylor's on his way to
second and he has a lead off double
two for three night for chris taylor
and he strikes out
second time tonight he's found walks
away shaking his head in between the two
k's he had a single and now look what
happens taylor just takes third base the
ball was mishandled on the exchange from
mccann to smith
you know i was looking down to record
the strikeout on my scorecard and a
simple toss back from the catcher to the
pitcher it gets away like a little
league play here's billy mckinney with
the infield in
this ball is whacked to right center
field
and it's run down on the warning track
by nimmo and yet another sacrifice fly
and it becomes four nothing
it's not essentially a swing and miss
pitch as you think 101 would be
pitcher spot michael conforto pinch hits
that's a fair ball down the right field
line he's on his way to second
as mckinney digs it out of the corner
and a two out pinch it double for
michael conforto
this is where bruhl fits in good lane
for him here with smith and nimmo smith
loops one into center field it's going
to drop and the mets are going to wind
up on the scoreboard the throw comes to
the plate the call from the plate umpire
chris conroy is that conforto is in
there so now it's up to mcneil who came
in in the sixth as a pinch hitter and
struck out
in the air to shallow center field here
comes belliger closing ground he can't
get to it it drops in
and two runs score
it's a 4-3 game
soft contact but well placed
suddenly some drama
at city field
and it gets away not in the dirt up high
and this is a tie game
what a nightmare inning for the dodgers
and there goes aureus's 14th win the
lack of execution by the dodgers
stunning now it's up to muncie base hit
could give the dodgers the lead in the
night something's going on a light or
something that is in muncie's eyes or
something that's distracting him yeah
he's down the left field line yeah you
can see that little green flash it's one
of those laser pointers it appears to be
you see it's
yeah you would hope that this is a case
where fans
would realize this is a dangerous
situation you see two for five two home
runs
and he strikes him out
strange inning
but diaz gets through it without the
dodgers putting up the go-ahead run
starts the ending at second here's the
3-2 pitch
a high-fly ball to deep left field down
the line and into the seats
muncie trots home ahead of smith will's
16th homer of the season
makes it 6-4 dodgers in the 10th three
rbis tonight for smith he had a sac fly
earlier the last time kenley janssen
pitched two complete innings it was in
the 2018 post season not going
a chopper
taylor's got it throws across the
diamond
and that takes care of er
alonzo scores it's six to five neato has
never faced jansen
swings at the first pitch it's a fly
ball to the left
and that is that
six five dodgers in ten